a few years ago I stumbled across this
video that compiled the first and last
shots of famous movies and I wondered to
myself can the same thing be applied to
dialogue
consider this an experiment is there any
correlation between the first line of
dialogue and a film and the last so I've
taken the top 50 films on IMDB and I'll
play those lines you be the judge you're
in some motel room now
are you watching closely you don't
really want to work it out
you want to be fooled life's not fair is
it
[Music]
still lovin
I'm sorry I'm sorry no Geoffrey's
congratulations
[Music]
October is inventory time
so right now Statler toyota is making
the best deals of the year rose we don't
need roads poison is still fresh three
days they're following us buy a drink
No
drink three billion human lives ended on
August 29th 1997 because of a machine a
terminator can learn the value of human
life maybe we can - I don't want to be a
product of my environment I want my
environment to be a product of me okay I
lost got the factory they may know
something section five speed her up for
one
[Music]
well the coming of the Second World War
many eyes in imprisoned Europe turned
hopefully or desperately toward the
freedom of the Americas Louis I think
this is the beginning of a beautiful
friendship
[Music]
if you want any tickets you'll have to
go around go away go ahead I want you to
see me die never did eat your lunch did
you well she wouldn't even have a just
being what the [ __ ] are you thinking
there's a black guy outside he's
breaking into your car the mystic chords
of memory will swell when again touched
as surely they will be by the better
angels of our nature
the green model who seemed so long oh my
was a farmer like everybody else back
then knew a lot a chemist a Leone I
think we'll be okay earlier
Gero most of the day off I don't and
like that he's gone questa una storia
same bleacher a puttin on a fattie
larrikin Darla I all everything the
George Bailey help that's right that's
right
[Music]
neighbors heard them screaming at each
other like for two hours there was
nothing no the world is a fine place and
worth fighting for I agree with the
second part
he'll be all right
I just conceded to see him as me show me
a bush repair I gotta so we also added a
quiche photographer
I don't know helps your busting I
started Illinois yeah is everything in
place where we go from there is a choice
I leave to you is that I get to live the
rest of my life like a schnook
good morning miss Freddie
[Music]
echo three to echo seven ah nobody do
you read me
may the force be with you hello my
name's Forrest Forrest Gump of course
your smile forced them the world is
changed we're glad you're with me people
are always asking me if I know Tyler
Durden do you have a very strange time
you got it's too risky
I think we should be leaving now yes
probably
[Music]
three of a kind let's do this good night
[Music]
I believe in America America as it made
my fortune mr. Dufresne described the
confrontation you had with your wife the
night that she was murdered
I hope the Pacific is as blue as it has
been in my dreams I hope
[Music]